die familie aus cottbus wollte auf
mallorca eigentlich nur die frische
mittelmeerluft genießen doch das ganze
wurde zu einem alptraum nach ihrer
rückkehr wurde bekannt dass sich mit dem
corona virus infiziert haben
das ganze aber nicht weise symptome
zeigen sondern bei einer der arbeitgeber
danach einen corona test forderte wir
möchten jetzt als allererstes direkt
nach mallorca schauen zu meinem kollegen
kirch wird darüber sprechen wie die
situation auf mallorca momentan ist kann
jetzt mit diesem fall das ist die
nächste schlechte nachricht für mallorca
in diesen corona zeiten in urlaubszeiten
haben die mallorquiner jetzt angst dass
der tourismus sich dieses jahr gar nicht
mehr fangen kann
ich denke mal das ist das schlimmste was
passieren konnte nach der ganzen
ballermann auf geschichte die wir
gesehen haben dass die leute sich nicht
angehalten haben das jetzt noch eine
familie sich infizierten corona ist
natürlich der super gau für die
touristen weißt du was die behörden
jetzt unternehmen um sicherzustellen
dass die familie nicht noch andere
menschen vielleicht angesteckt haben in
diesem urlaub also ich hörte davon dass
natürlich das hotel erst mal gesucht
wird was wahrscheinlich irgendwie im
norden sein müsste weil er die ganzen
familien hotels darauf sind da wird
fieberhaft gesucht gerade jetzt welches
und will es gewesen sein könnte und das
wird natürlich erst mal abgesperrt um
natürlich andere nicht anzustecken
die maßnahmen auf mallorca werden jetzt
immer strenger um gegen korona
anzukämpfen gibt es momentan aktuelle
zahlen oder entwicklungen ob tatsächlich
fälle auch wieder steigen auf der insel
also bis jetzt habe ich habe ich davon
nichts gehört es ist ja eigentlich
ziemlich im safe ja alles die kontrollen
am flughafen oder auf den straßen jetzt
die massen pflicht war ja eingeführt
vorgestern
da gibt es also viele kontrollen voller
poesie lokal also der wird schon
ziemlich hart durchgegriffen
um schlimmeres zu verhindern in lankwitz
live aus mallorca